[Music]
okay
don't we're now recording so we're
unlike the daily show last night when
you said we were doing drugs
i you know chris rock is here everybody
yeah
um i he's he he's spoken of on this
podcast often
fondly fondly fondly yeah he's the
shadow executive
of the shadow exactly never heard it
never will hear it
but you know you you we both play a
large role in one another's lives
over the phone now he's going to deny it
um
and um and uh it's nice to be here it's
nice to have you
i appreciate you welcome to my home yes
this is your rental home
it's my california yeah nice as i work
on machiavelli
as i work on my new opus and you're
doing press
for fargo season four and also your
learning disability you seem to be doing
i wasn't really
you know you know things come out
neil why
the public me i'm just you know and it's
easier than
apologizing to a lot of people
individually so you just
just i was safe do it over the airwaves
yeah oh okay i guess
it was very satisfying for me for you to
have a learning
disability because um careful careful
that was very satisfying for me because
we would argue about your our different
styles
basically i feel like i made you less
cynical
and you made me more cynical
meaning i have the i have that effect on
people
on the world in some way i have that
effect on people
and i would argue that i made you
slightly i made you
realize that there is uh
value to feelings
it's not i never didn't think there were
value to feelings
deal uh maybe
there's value to my feelings yeah
there's value to there's
like your sort of gruff old exterior
well i'm you know
you know i'm always like okay i'm the
head of the family
right right so you know me and my kids
and
you know sometimes i'm the boss at work
more times than not so
my feelings don't matter in the overall
pantheon of moving things forward
right you know we can't slow down for my
feelings
would you say that you found out that
you kind of need to though
i need to slow down individually yes
but i will never inflict my feelings on
others
you inflicted your feelings on others by
not addressing your feelings
so then you i bet that the next time you
run a thing
or you run a an organization yeah you'll
be
your management style will be different
than it was would have been five years
ago
probably probably a little bit from
being like
softer nah i mean it's
weird there's a bunch of jobs i won't
even take just because
just producing things and directing
things because some of them
especially like like a nightly show or
you know some certain things just
required an urgency
yeah yeah and you know sometimes you
have to raise your voice
when things get urgent yeah uh but
raising your voice is against the law
now
so i will not take the job
i will politely passing them okay
yeah you know and and then you gotta
assess what
piece of talent you're working with so
some people
don't need to be pushed you know jimmy
butler of the miami heat does not need
to be pushed yeah
but tyler harold might need a foot in
his ass you know what i mean like
he might well that's the thing about
riley is he's apparently like a real
hard ass
like and practice i didn't realize
there's a lakers book
right uh called showtime about the 80s
lakers and
he would practice the [ __ ] out of them
which it would i didn't know that
well he the miami heat or the la
pat riley's teams are always the best
conditioned teams in the league
they it's very rare those guys get tired
yeah they are they're like fat i guess
shaq was fat
they're like track stars right shaq was
the one okay
yeah yeah he could have a doughnut but
the rest of you [ __ ] yeah
that to get this salad uh and that's
exactly that's how you like my pet riley
that's a good pet ralph yeah
um okay i would say now
i want to play a game because we don't
listen the game is going to be called
this bianca
it's going to be true or false bianca's
trying to mick jagger mario bianca he
did
bianca jagger that's another the uh
the uh we're gonna try to guess
what it's a chris rock believe it or not
true false whatever i'll have you try to
guess what
this is great okay we're gonna start
with um
i'm doing three mics live in new york
city
right chris rock would call me
almost every day and say what bianca
god is it fill in the blank
yeah yeah yeah um what would i say what
do you think he would say to somebody
doing
some successful one-person show okay
something negative
get rid of one of those mics or no you
did give me a good note which is stay in
the mic
area that was a good note but he would
call me just about every day and go
don't kill yourself
why kill yourself don't kill yourself
now i know
that he's a grizzled detective and then
that's his way of showing and also
i really didn't want you to kill
yourself that's right
oh obviously this is a man who's thought
about killing himself
the kid in pain so what do you say yeah
god it's
obviously well you say you've got a lot
of thought about killing
what a normal person says hey man how
you doing but
you being a grizzly detective well i
just get to the point yes they're all
[ __ ] they don't
what they're really trying to say is
don't kill yourself don't kill yourself
um great i just wanted to get that out
at least that was what if you killed
yourself and all those people got
together they would all go did anybody
tell him not to kill himself and i don't
know
how he was and i'd be like i feel good
i'm gonna go have a minute my conscience
you guys sit here and cry
i know i told him not to kill himself um
i have a joke with uh our friend dave
chappelle which
chris's love language is open hostility
[Laughter]
some people give gifts some people words
of encouragement chris rock
open
[Laughter]
i thought it was just fighting humor
yeah no it is
it was biting humor but it was there's
some truth to it you know what i'm just
saying you know
bianca chris's aunt had a cat
what was that cat's name fill in the
blink um my cat
my aunt's but so he doesn't have to say
it my aunt's cat's
name was [ __ ] hart r
hard r this is also the aunt who said
who said
uh this is also the aunt that said uh a
broke man is like a broke hand
can't do nothing with it
do you were you close with them with
this on yeah yeah yeah
is she is she still around nah she's she
died while back would she call for the
cat
yes she would she would call [ __ ]
like my aunt yeah would you almost come
before you remember the cat's name
look i gotta make that joke legally
um so funny okay now
what now in at chris's school in
1975 this is what the first year but you
were in the first year of busing
i was bust let's say okay i'm
born in 65 so in 75 i'm
10. see how long it took me to realize
that
it's that learning disability i've
literally had to count it
uh so i'm 75 and 10 so i would say in um
what's funny so you're born in 65
dr king's a lot yes that's the thing of
like how
how much like the voting rights act the
voting rights act
doesn't happen until 68. so i'm born my
parents can't vote
wow i mean they can but it's it's
it's they're gonna get like as you
pointed out a few weeks ago like they're
gonna get
probably [ __ ] up yeah they're at the
polls yeah they're gonna get the ass
kicked
but that what's what's important about
that is not that martin luther king was
so long ago it's that it was so recent
yes
you're so old it's that that wasn't that
long ago no
uh yeah yes he is paranoid his parents
you're the oldest i'm the oldest of my
mother's kids yeah
so could not could not vote
did they vote the first year i have no
idea yeah
um i have no no no they didn't like make
it i mean they eventually voted but yeah
i don't you know um fantastic okay
now chris is busted one of the first
years of bussing okay
now so 73 72 70 72 73
when the black kid there were how many
like 10 percent of the school was buying
no no no no no no it was
me for my ps277 was me and
three girls three black girls out of i
don't know it was a school
800 a thousand yeah something like that
yeah
four kids out of a so you would get
at when the bell would ring yeah
everyone would you'd well that grade
school was
grade school like my first days of grade
school i remember like you know there
was like parents outside with like signs
no bussing oh my god [ __ ] go home
whatever right
that was grade school and it was you
know it was hostile and
kids would call you [ __ ] and spit on
you and throw back
regular stuff bags of [ __ ] and piss at
you for the holidays
but um for the holidays
for the holidays you know occasional
teachers would call you a monkey or
whatever yeah please that's the story
i'm trying to get
teachers explain these stories going
somewhere
except i just would tell you [ __ ] some
of your breath janitors
belle would ring at three in high school
or one time
one time or a couple of times i i just
remember
yeah cause we used to get out like they
would let us out at 2 45. they let the
black kids out early
so they wouldn't get beat up yeah dude
kind of like
get that over with because you don't
want to just it's easier to watch you
so we get out at 2 45 in 1700 yeah and
that was uh
so i remember one of my teachers ah time
to let the animals free or something
time to let the animals free yeah um and
then the janitor said something you said
uh something else savages or some adults
yeah just
wow everyone's against you just
everything i mean it wasn't even me
it was like you and four other people it
was just
whatever they were just against black
people yeah it was just yeah they
weren't
they didn't probably didn't know my name
uh
insane yeah and you don't have you in
therapy and all the [ __ ] you're doing
are you acknowledging
that how crazy that is i yeah it's weird
i've always been able to tell jokes
about it
but yeah now in therapy i'm i'm allowed
to
you know experience it as trauma yeah
you can say and not feel like a [ __ ]
feel like and now i feel like a
[ __ ] and yeah and like i'm i'm
a lot i should that's a fine thing to
acknowledge that happens
it's a fine thing to acknowledge and
it's also um
you know the thing about trauma is when
you when you experience trauma it's not
that you
it's basically whenever you think about
it you think about it
like it's happening for the first time
yeah your body doesn't know
when it doesn't know if it's present
past or future right
so yeah therapy's allowed me to put it
in the past like therapy's allowed me to
go
okay i'm probably not gonna get jumped
today yeah which is hard which it took
me a long time to like
get there you now having said that you
were getting jumped
later into your career than i remember
that i would have you know
i've got [ __ ] i got robbed the last time
i got robbed was
like the first week i was on snl but uh
what happened he still makes me laugh on
dekalb avenue oh no
i was walking up to cowboy avenue and
some guys punched me in the face and
pulled a gut on me
and uh yeah i mean
big deal yeah uh i lived in brooklyn
yeah big deal
i lived in brooklyn before it was hit i
mean i lived i was born i was
born in south carolina raised in
brooklyn but i never
moved to manhattan when i did snl
because i knew i couldn't get a cab
right so i had to have a car it cost
whatever 300
dollars a month to park a car and
you need a permit or something right
right so yeah it's just like it costs
too much to park a car in manhattan so i
gotta live in brooklyn
yeah because i didn't want like farley
to have to get me a cab
every day was it known that can't get
really funny yeah
it was i mean it was i mean it's still
known nowadays
but now i'm kind of an old man so it's
like no like in the night
late early late 80s early 90s early 90s
yeah
i was 20 whatever but i looked a lot
younger yeah nobody no cab would stop
you know pre uber pre yeah
yeah like it was whatever it's not i'm
not no no it's just
i'm not gonna sit here and act like i
just liked how late you got robbed
yeah didn't you have a black eye yeah my
snl cast photo there's a lot of makeup
on
no because i kind of had a black eye
it's a black and white picture so it's
hard to tell but
my makeup's so thick
because i don't [ __ ] black out do you
think do you think phil hartman or
kevin nealon had the same problem no no
maybe phil hartman phil hartman had more
problems
yeah it turns out it turns out it turns
out um phil was living far more
dangerous explain
to bianca the
what happened to the mcdonald's in your
neighborhood because i i have a hard
time explaining this to people in a
believable i lived in a poor
neighborhood
my neighbor was so poor that our
mcdonald's went out of business
uh mcdonald's on broadway
and i believe koscielsko right around
there
was literally they might have opened it
back
up since then but yeah and like
literally a mcdonald's
boarded up like they couldn't make it
work they couldn't compete with the
chinese
restaurants yeah chicken wings like
they couldn't a two dollar sandwich was
too they could not
[ __ ] with the bodega no
um yeah we had a mcdonald's go out of
business okay this is true
this is another true story that neil
marvel's at my life yeah yes neil's
writing your biography
explained to beyonce benjamin button or
something what happened
like i have some great tales what
happened
what did bullies you said that bullies
will imitate whatever they've seen
in a movie well i'm just saying okay
here's
here's what neil's alluding to i'm i
don't know
can we look up what year deliverance
came out in in
uh deliverance right yeah deliverance
came out in
75 i believe yeah so in 75
deliverance comes out yes i'm 10. and
the common thing was for guys
to like gang up on one of their friends
and
kind of try to rape them smell like a
pig
squirrel like a pig like a pepper squirt
like a pig with some real [ __ ]
you're from a different planet i'm from
a different planet like
that [ __ ] was like yo yeah people think
like cyberbullying is a problem right
no no no you're having cyberbullying
reynolds was the biggest star in the
world
was basically the rock okay he was like
that because it wasn't
just that he was he was such a big star
and yeah that was the number one scene
the most talked about scene
john white reynolds i got john no it was
uh
ned beatty and deliverance
and that was very common
for a lot of like yeah [ __ ] went down
i never got raped but dude people were
getting raped or
just definitely the attempted rapes
were for real at like house parties at
house park just like
yeah whatever just like you're around
talking about this enough
i've never heard of it before before he
said it on the phone
thousands of men get raped no no i know
that i just mean like as a playful
bullying thing
yes 70s were different thousands of men
get raped every year
they were playing tackle that tag yeah
and a lot of them
and a lot of them happen in locker rooms
and stuff yeah
you know yeah that's the like they're
[ __ ] like that like i would hear about
circle jerks i've never seen that in my
life
that seems like some prep school [ __ ]
yeah so whereas in the
in locker rooms it was uh yeah it was uh
yeah
deliverance was the big movie um
that's so insane and hilarious to me and
just insane
yeah um i'm from a different planet yes
chris's father used to say
about uh if you were trying to make a
decision
what do you think his father would say
about making a decision just yes
um i i don't know
you need to make a decision before the
white man makes one for you
because you're not gonna like his
decision so you better
figure this [ __ ] out right now some
true before the white man jumps in on
this [ __ ]
will you explain what your father's
job was because it's an interesting like
his role
okay my father was a truck driver right
and he drove for
lots of places new york daily news
wrangle brewery
shulman's furs whatever he drove for a
lot of places
but um one of his jobs was uh they would
call him
when um basically when they were trying
to break the union
and get black guys in like the teamsters
or whatever right
and so my father would go like my
father's probably like the first black
one of the first black drivers at
wrangle brewery one of the first black
drivers at the new york daily news
him and maybe two other guys right and
one of the reasons they chose my father
is because he could take it
much like the same reason jack jackie
robinson's the 18th
best black baseball player right but he
gets chosen because his demeanor
he's the most stoic he's the most stoic
he can put up with this [ __ ] and keep
playing he's not going to jump in the
stands and
punch somebody in the face and
so your dad was just he would get
harassed basically yeah my dad would get
harassed
as you will as by the way it's the same
thing people throwing piss and [ __ ] at
you and whatever it's
you've seen gangs in new york it's very
much the same gangster
late 1800s go ahead but but
but the but the spirit's the exact the
spirit is exactly the same
uh yeah so my dad could take it and
later on in life
i could take it i have a very high
threshold for
like pain and people doing
horrible [ __ ] to me has that served you
do you think or do you wish you were a
little bit more affected
it served me in business right
it has not served me in my personal you
know
definitely situations i probably should
have yeah
said something about oh like you'll go
you'll take
[ __ ] from people yeah yeah just
friends and whatever yeah this site
people making i should podcast i should
have raised my voice
um very i should have
uh i should yeah but that's almost like
i was saying on the way over here people
parents didn't have no one had good
childhoods before like 1980.
like the idea of a good childhood is
like a fairly new concept
well yeah i mean parents were basically
judged
80 of a parent's grade was attendance
yeah right now it's like 50 of your
greatest attendance
yeah but it used to be well my dad's
here yeah
yeah that's all it took yeah he hit me
and he threw a bag of piss at me but
he's here i saw my mom she fed us every
day that was all it
really required now it's like yeah yeah
you have to be decent
yeah you got to be better with personnel
oh you know i was going to ask you
that's i think it's good to call your
children personality
i think that's a good approach that's a
really good approach what
has having daughters
taught you about women
because i i noticed i was having a
conversation
with another friend of ours who has a
daughter and he's like yeah but she's a
daughter so
he was like letting her daughter uh deal
with emotions in a different way than he
would of his son
well what has it taught me about women
it hasn't taught me a lot honestly i
know as a womanologist you kind of like
i mean put this way it's it you're right
your son is different
and the re the reality is the whole
world stops for a crying woman
the whole company will stop what is
wrong with pam
yes ain't nobody's stopping fulfilled
man
yeah phil better get back to
[ __ ] work
yeah what the [ __ ] is up with
[ __ ] phil
don't be doing all that [ __ ] and the
dance man
what the [ __ ] is up with phil somebody
talk to that [ __ ]
yeah so yeah no but you i would say
you're a whiteologist and a womanologist
and i was wondering
if i i mean no one's a womanologist
i mean your daughter's it's impossible
it's it's [ __ ] impossible you can't
yeah they don't have enough time you
just don't ever
too many variations just try to please
and you can't get a straight answer from
women about what they're like [ __ ]
try to float just try to please you guys
went to the same university
i just hey i just try to please i got no
i just try to please yeah i got what's
my joke i got
daughters 19 a daughter i got daughters
18 a daughter that's
16 and i got an ex-wife that's
50 50 and i got a mother that's 75.
when they don't get what they want they
sound exactly the same
yeah you've said that joke to me yes if
i show you their test if i showed you
the transcript
you couldn't tell them apart it's a
betrayal
on like a absolute spiritual level was
chris rock a signed rapper
at any point a signed rapper i assigned
or a side rapper assigned rapper uh
yes yes i was assigned rapper i think i
was
i think it was atlantic there's demos
out there somewhere
wait you you really wanted to rap i'm
from [ __ ]
i'm born in 65 i saw grandmaster flash
play in the park
i've been to the disco he's still hoping
to be a rapper
i'm like i'm that guy do you have any
mixtapes lying around
oh somewhere sign rapper now dj
dj before i ever told a joke
it was it was actually not bad could you
know
cut backspin ever ever should you brag
could you break dance no i could never
break dance but
big dancing is so hard it's all abs yeah
and then you
you saw so you were rapping maybe and
scratching
working a red lobster then you saw eddie
at radio city
lobster i saw
delirious it was like oh
okay that's what i should be doing uh
with the radio city story is basically
me online
it's like one of those things my
father's got the paper
we're the only people on the block with
the new york times and
it's a big full-page ad eddie murphy's
going to be playing radio city
tickets go on sale tomorrow okay i'll
get there at 11 o'clock
and buy some tickets this is back
yeah no it's prehistoric times where you
have to go to a place to buy it
it's prehistoric so the line
was six city blocks long oh my god
the longest line you've ever seen in
your life it was it was like it was like
one of those depression lines
yeah yeah like that like one of those
depression lines like
eddie murphy's going to be in a building
yeah in six months
you know anyway i'm yes i'll wait
i'll wait then i get online and i'm just
reading my paper and
like comic strip
hmm edition night maybe i should go
there and i left line and
walked from radio city to the comic
strip
audition night was not that night they
sent me to catch
i went to catch there was about
40 people outside waiting to pick a
number of one of seven numbers
you pick a number and if you you know
you pick one of those seven numbers you
get to perform that night
i got number seven uh
i'd never performed ever had you
thought of [ __ ] to maybe i was thinking
of [ __ ] online
while i was on the line do you mean in
in the last in the line i'm like
the 80s online meant you were in a line
i was on the line i'm confused
and um by the way
of the 40 people maybe 30 of them had
already auditioned before and it was
just a normal thing
like they just went back like you see
open bikers the same open micros
and uh so they're all like oh your first
time
oh okay this is good get this one under
your belt
you know by your this is my ninth or
whatever you know
one day you'll be good or whatever the
[ __ ] whatever it was
anyway cut two i'm the only guy that
passed
that night that night and bait and you
had
the the joke you had the one butler had
passed the week before me
rest in peace i'm kidding yes she's
alive right
yeah oh she looks great yeah she was
funny it was like my bud
uh the uh and you had here comes the
neighborhood
right maybe uh maybe i got it that night
yeah i think i did have it that night
you you you what were you talking about
just
no recollection i said some bad joke
about
miles davis's so black lightning bugs
follow him into daytime
and i don't know maybe
two more minutes of jokes and i kind of
killed
yeah and did you feel like oh [ __ ] were
you like
i shouldn't be killing or like this is
easy it was more like this is easy it
wasn't like i shouldn't be killing it
um you know my like what's the big deal
what's the big deal
this is coming waiting for eddie murphy
and i proceeded to
kill for about three weeks yeah
so my first three weeks i'm annihilating
wow i'm killing to the point they're
like thinking about bringing in the snl
people to see you
like my first year right and
i brought a girl i had a girlfriend i
know how this story goes
and i brought kim and
i proceeded to bomb for the next three
years no
yeah that's what happened i proceeded to
it was it took me three years to even
get
back to that point what do you think it
was
just one of them saying you know that
thing that confidence and arrogance
once you get that like the comedian
can't get to that arrogant place
yeah gotta be confident but once you
cross that line
yeah it's like [ __ ] you yeah is it that
the failure
you just that like threw you off the f
well i was probably too cocky up there
first of all i was young as
[ __ ] you know and i looked yeah 19 20
like 19 20 and i looked but i
looked like 13 yeah i mean i was i
weighed like 130 pounds or something
oh you couldn't find clothes that fit
yeah like like i was
that picture of you before in 1990
nothing fits yeah
everything is too big i was so skinny
all right
um so i really you know a lot of
stand-up is you know
there's a reason there's no justin
bieber of comedy yeah
there's no little way like eddie
murphy's the closest thing we've ever
had to a young comedian and
all the rest of them are 30 years old
right yeah
to start yeah there's one
young guy one guy that was 22 and
[ __ ] ripped it
but all the rest of them are kind of
grown men
and women and so i was young
and one and part of the reason it's just
no one believes you
when you're that young yeah yeah i mean
there's no point of view there's no
you have no point of view it's like it's
like what do you know yeah
what the [ __ ] do you know kid shut the
[ __ ] up
but they'll take miles davis being black
yeah yeah you don't need to
any any age can see that yeah take your
silly [ __ ] but
um dude would you have you ever talked
about
why your family moved up from south
carolina um
is that is that like like allegedly
somebody i don't know here's a is i hate
all civil rights movies
don't get me wrong i applaud the effort
right
and and they should exist the problem is
they only show the back of the bus and
the lunch counter
they actually make racism look very like
fixable
right they don't really get into how
dysfunctional
the the the relationships
were and like in the 40s and 50s
like white men would just walk in your
house and take your food
you know like yeah they would just
come into your house they wouldn't know
what do you think would happen in the
during the depression
when people are hungry and white people
are hungry
and and like oh there's black people
cooking on that side of town
what do you think would happen they
would walk in your house and take your
take a predator prayer relationship it's
a predator-prey relationship
what do you think white guys what do you
think when it was time to rape they
would just rape they were raping white
women no they would
go and rape the women they could
actually rape without going to jail for
okay or sexual assault just like you
know
guys and all that [ __ ] you know all that
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] is so much more um
[Music]
you know racism and jim crow is so much
dirtier than any movie
ever shows it's in it's insidious it's
in every single
yeah the amount of rules
that existed i mean you were probably
going to get to this at some point like
i always tell the story of my mother
used to get her teeth taken out
at the vet yeah yeah because you weren't
allowed to go to the dentist like like
no
no movie shows you that yeah it's just
like oh well if
we give them some eggs they'll be fine
yeah we just got a knot why are you
gonna figure out this
plating the seating once we've allowed
it
squared away they can get the grand slam
breakfast at denny's why are they
marching
but there was the thing where someone
kind of got left behind
at why your family had to move yeah
something happened with
somebody got killed he'll knows more
some stories somebody might have
somebody there might be a dead white
person somewhere
because if they if time to go girls came
into the house no no
they got one three of them were done i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna
give this story any justice but but
maybe something there's
a few of my friends have similar stories
too like
some violence went down and the black
people were the family had to
get out of the south pretty great
racism everybody just google it yeah
um why do you why do i
no hey explain the social me the steve
carlton thing that's the
steve carlton steve the you and i don't
like
preening on social media which a lot of
people do like a lot of people like
cons constant self congratulations on
social media yeah
and you and i are not fans of it and you
say it's because al franken
and conan used to just like well al
franken it's so weird that people
get in people get in so much trouble now
for being
for bussing balls but yeah
thank god these [ __ ] were just
mean and condescending to me
because and it was like conan
conan and smigiel
actually odenkirk was really nice i mean
by the way conan and those guys got
there right they're not like you [ __ ]
they weren't
they weren't they weren't delivering to
me they're just like
you know putting me in my place at the
time uh
but one of the great stories that helped
my career out
was uh al franken pulls me to the side
because i had a really good
show uh the michael jordan show michael
jordan when he hosted sorry when he
hosted
snl michael jordan with musical guest
public enemy
the oh my god what a show
it was the season premiere in 1991
anyway
and i had a really good show and then
the next week i had a bad show
and one of the reasons i had a bad show
is because i was again
it's the same thing about tell being
really funny getting too cocky
and trying to find that place again
but uh al franken told me this story
about uh this pitcher
steve carlton
probably the best left-handed pitcher in
the history of baseball a second
randy johnson would be number one steve
called number two right
uh so steve carlton would only
pitch if this guy tim mccarver would
catch him
that was the deal if colton pitches
mcarthur catches him
so you know the game isn't just physical
the game's mental
baseball right and they found that
some hitters if they let them get a hit
early in the game they wouldn't try as
hard later in the game so there were
certain guys that would
let get on base it's like just throw
this guy easy fastball
let him get on base and we don't got to
worry about that guy later
he's so selfish he's just gonna be like
i got mine
whatever happens happens and franken's
like that's what happened with you
you got yours at the michael jordan show
and then next week you're just too
cocky and relaxed and you gotta have
that hunger every night
so al franken kind of saved my life wow
so i go hard yeah that's why that's what
i try
i know and the thing that i like about
you is you try
like you doing the press you were saying
that you had like me
or you told me you had a mirror and
microphone stand set up in your house
for years before bringing the pain which
is like
that makes sense yeah that you were
actually
practicing i practice
all the time yeah yeah it's not
like easy or fluid or
yeah i have an snl question if you stay
in shape you don't have to get in shape
well hello
jimmy fallon would laugh and people like
is is there something when you're doing
the
sketches breaking the fourth wall or
kind of like why did people get annoyed
at it because there was something funny
when you it's kind of new
because when i was there you would get
in trouble for laughing you would you
could not just be like
we're doing a show no i was like yo this
ain't the cal burnett show
like no disrespect to cow burnette but
that was
yeah when i was doing snl you laughing
during the thing was not
you know was not encouraged to put it
that way so it was just like no we got
to keep it together
yeah we keep it together here that makes
sense um
here's a good one which is worse which
is where slavery or jim crow
wow they're both you've said you've
you've your answer
we've spoken about this before and it's
a well i mean your thoughts on this
the thing about slavery is like slavery
is slavery
it has rules you know you're a slave
other people have been slaves
yeah the thing about jim crow is like
this
fake reality yeah that we're free
and yeah
i mean i don't even know how to answer
this i mean when people say slavery
ended
whatever years ago i always go no
slavery ended i count jim crow as part
of slavery yeah
as far as i'm concerned slavery ended in
1975.
that's when i'm like okay i'm black i
kind of have some shot of making this
thing work it ain't
the playing field is not equal but there
are
avenues and caves of success i can go
into
75 the thing is 10 years after
my birth yeah you said
you put it in perspective you get you go
ahead and i'm not exaggerating
yeah you said you understand slavery but
jim crow is just
[ __ ] mean well jim crow is just the
meanest
that you're just you have sadistic
captors
yeah yeah it's like oh we got guys
okay we we have this thing because we
want people to work our land
i can kind of understand that on some
level
this other [ __ ] water fountains
and all this [ __ ] and all these you have
you ever crack open a jim crow book
they're really thick and the amount of
laws just about just walking down the
street and
what okay and you're walking but if a
white woman's walking your way you have
to jump you have to be in the gutter you
can't
be on the sidewalk and like all of this
[ __ ]
that's you know and in some states may
even
still be on the books yeah
you know there's a ton of rules about
you know how much bread you can buy it's
ridiculous how
intricate it was yeah it's [ __ ] mean
it's mean
it's just so mean in closing we're
closing we're almost done
because we gotta do we gotta do the
thing we gotta do drugs chris yeah
oh wait i have a question yeah go ahead
okay i have questions what are the
questions
what's the most expensive gift you've
ever given a woman
i'm not even going to say yeah you know
some
somebody's going to be pissed that's why
he can't say that okay next
i'm not gonna say but she knows what it
is okay
okay do you have any phobias do i have
any
phobias do you have any phobias i don't
think i do
i think i can think of one i said why
are you
if you have money or you didn't i didn't
bring up you just said the reason you're
doing
arenas and pushing so hard
my phobia being poor yes yeah yeah more
specific
i don't want to be just at well dave
actually just said this on letterman
on the letterman thing like i like being
famous yeah
i do not want to be the miscellaneous
black dude
you said you didn't want to go back to
being your auntie's hat
yeah yeah thank you let's let's not get
in trouble
dale you didn't want to go back to that
i don't want to go back okay
does it okay does being famous
feel the way you imagined it when you
weren't famous just being
and you know i never thought about it
when i wasn't famous you weren't like
you but like as an open miker come on
you could be like yo i'mma kill it like
eddie and no it's a weird dog because my
name is
actually chris rock you just knew and
no no no i just had this weird okay so
if you're the only black kid
only black boy in your grade in your
whole
school guess what you're famous oh yeah
everybody [ __ ] knows who you are yeah
you know
yes you're already you already you know
no one's asking for your autograph or
anything but i'm known
as a [ __ ] um is there people are
pointing
but it's for the wrong reason it's for
the wrong reason yeah
um was there uh what's the i had a
police escort
but not for our reasons
of fame um what's
the biggest letdown and the biggest
surprise about being famous
i don't know i mean
like can you get away with [ __ ] like can
you no
especially now you really can't get away
with [ __ ] uh yeah that's true
what is the biggest letdown
i don't know the only let down to me is
you can't cut it off
and i don't really feel like caring
about my appearance
that much yeah yeah so tell me about it
okay i just like oh god
yeah probably the number one reason i
never took any of these talk show offers
because i don't want to
care i don't want to think about my
[ __ ] appearance ever you've got to
get a haircut every day you're going to
get
yeah no it's a pain it takes 45 it takes
like
there's nothing funny about it there's
nothing funny about vanity
speaking of which who would you say
in person is the had a
charismatic effect over women a rapper
you've said it before that that women
would be shocked to hear
biggie yes yeah biggie had lots of women
coming after him like before he was that
popular
i feel like he rapped about having a lot
of women but you didn't believe it
because it's a big fat [ __ ]
i believe that's what was not about it
fake he was a very charismatic
cat the couple of times i saw him was
like yeah they were
autumn they were autumn god bless them
god bless them um and in closing what
you're at a nightclub in atlanta
and a dwarf lady is trying to get your
attention
yeah that was funny i was at the club
yes
you know i was i was in my pookie from
new jack city days
and girls are coming up to me or
whatever and this
girl i guess she's a little personal
person yeah and she's like where you
staying i was like nah come on
and then she goes can't blame a [ __ ]
for trying
i'll always love her for that chris rock
ladies and gentlemen
yay we're probably
gonna do a legal [ __ ] that's honey
business god bless
goodbye
[Music]
um
how